and this morning we're learning more
about the 10 victims killed
in that senseless mass shooting at a
boulder colorado supermarket they range
in ages from 20
to 65. they include a veteran police
officer
employees at the king super's grocery
store where the shooting took place and
a young man
who wanted to be a pilot the suspect 21
year old ahmad alissa faces
10 counts of first-degree murder for
allegedly killing people with a weapon
he bought just six days before the
shooting
the violence has inspired and renewed
the debate over gun laws in this country
earlier on cbs this morning we spoke
about that with vice president kamala
harris
it is time for congress to act and stop
with the false choices
this is not about getting rid of the
second amendment it's simply about
saying we need reasonable gun safety
laws
there is no reason why we have assault
weapons on the streets of a civil
society they are weapons of war
they are designed to kill a lot of
people quickly
and they so often do our lead national
correspondent david begno is in boulder
colorado for us where we're going to
stay with the victims he spoke to two
friends of one of them david good
morning to you again
good morning last night i had a chance
to speak with janet and hope cotton
they were really close friends with a
woman named lynn murray lynne was one of
the victims and lynn had an interesting
life over the last
40 or so years she lived in a few
different places around the country
worked for some of the fashion magazines
in new york city
and then had jobs driving for uber but
most recently she was working for
instacart which is a service that
basically they go into the grocery store
they shop for you and then they deliver
turns out hope was actually in the
grocery store she ran into lynn
they chatted about food talked about hey
how you doing
it just so happened that hope checked
out got home
and heard that there was a shooting at
the grocery store and thought wait a
minute
i wonder if lynn was still inside
she was smiling we were laughing just
talking about
cauliflower and whatever else and you
know just doing it around she's like
this is a good order quick 50 bucks this
is hope cotton
she told us about the last time she saw
family friend len
murray just minutes before the shooting
started i checked out
and by the time that i got back here
which is barely a
five minute commute my little sister
called me like frantically and
you know just clicked to me i was like
lynn wasn't at the cash register yet and
i just like told my mom i'm like lynn's
in there still and then like when it
left my mouth i was kind of like oh no
and you know she turned right to her
phone to like
start texting lynn now the cotton spoke
with lynn's family
letting them know that she was still
inside the store hours after the rampage
was over
janet along with lynn's husband and
other victims families
were all gathered together waiting for
answers about their loved ones
but those answers didn't come for more
than 12 hours
i said to the whoever the police officer
was who was in charge
of the meeting i said okay well let's
just assume
there's 10 people and one of them was a
police officer
and so there's nine people and we're all
gathered in a room so are we gonna go
around and count how many families are
here
so everybody looked at each other and
they're like nine janet says it was just
after three a.m the next morning
that the coroner's office called lynn's
husband to tell him that she was gone
stomach and nuts trembling
[Music]
just everything you do when you're just
like
trying to keep it cool but you you're
letting it like the worst feelings and i
mean i love lynn
really still do dearly and how are you
dealing with the loss
this is my mom's best friend of like 20
years
i just want lynn's legacy to not
be this moment for none of these people
their legacies
these are just like names of people on a
list like these
are real souls that are loved and
like will continue to be loved now that
they're not here anymore
you know gail one of the things that
lennon hope was telling me was that
lynn and her family lived just right up
the street probably a two minute drive
from the grocery store
and they said david from now on lin's
family
is going to have to drive by that
grocery store every day
when they go somewhere every day they're
going to have to drive right by the
crime scene
i was wondering about that david i mean
there's a picture that we keep seeing on
the news you just showed it in your
piece of the bride the way she's looking
at her dad
who's no longer with us and then we
learn that she's now pregnant it's just
it's the stories you get me every time
thank you very much david